on prime crime tonight the dark truth
behind an adored family
this woman suffered this abuse all the
medications
feeding tube a shocking crime that
changed everything
her lungs would have literally been
floating in blood
and the twisted mind of a killer he
wanted you to clean up blood
right and he wanted you to clean naked
yes sir
[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime crime tonight
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases tonight
it's about a mother-daughter
relationship
that's straight out of a horror movie
claudine
dd blanchard and gypsy blanchard at
first glance they look like a loving
mother and daughter
those who knew them would say dede
relentlessly took care of her young girl
whoever since the age of eight was
suffering from numerous ailments like
leukemia
and muscular dystrophy the only problem
it was all a lie this woman
dede blanchard she held the ultimate
control
over gypsy to this young girl
gypsy she was a monster gypsy was in
fact
a healthy girl evidence would reveal
that dede deliberately fabricated her
daughter's medical conditions
she forced gypsy to be confined to a
wheelchair
shaved her head and sometimes had her
take medications
that would mimic symptoms of real
diseases
all of the years that gypsy had
suffered through with with surgeries
that were unnecessary procedures
this this perceived facade that she had
to carry on with
while it's not clear what caused dede to
do this her own mother was apparently
overbearing as well family members have
indicated a strained relationship
between the two
with some suggesting at the end dede
may have starved her mother to death
whatever may be the case
health professionals believe that when
it came to gypsy deedee may have been
showing signs of a mental illness called
munchausen syndrome by proxy
a caregiver is intentionally feigning
or actually committing some kind of
medical or psychological problem on the
person that they are supposed to be
caring for generally they do this
because
they appreciate the attention that they
get from having someone in their life
that needs significant medical or
psychological health
dede was able to con the public by
receiving donations
having the make a wish foundation pay
for a trip to disney world
and even allowing habitat for humanity
to build the two a house in springfield
missouri
despite signs that this was a farce dede
continually misled doctors and
caseworkers
there certainly has been questions as to
whether these doctors
should face the doctors who were
involved who treated her should face
some form of malpractice this is a
failure
of the health care system how can a
person
who is not ill see so many neurologists
oncologists and other doctors and not be
treated
for the majority of her life gypsy
didn't know the truth
in fact her mother convinced her she was
younger than she was
going so far as to change the dates on
her daughter's birth certificate
but by 19 gypsy was beginning to peel
back the layers
and started to act out you have to look
at gypsy as being suffering from
significant ongoing and long-term
abuse deep till tried to rebel she still
tried to engage in teenager
kinds of behaviors because she wanted
to feel safe and feel free and feel
normal
in 2012 the story takes a turn
she meets a young man from big ben
wisconsin named
nicholas godijon on a dating website
called
christiandatingforfree.com and forms a
relationship with him
she's still a developing human being who
will have
sexual needs and sexual urges she's
still gonna want to have
the life that she sees in the movies and
television shows that she watches
although they became girlfriend and
boyfriend pretty quickly
it would be years before they actually
met in person
they would consummate their love in 2015
by having sex
in a movie theater bathroom behind dd's
back
dede wasn't happy with the relationship
it didn't go well at all
my mother hated him from the moment they
met
three months later dede blanchard would
be dead
in june 2015 law enforcement enter the
blanchard house
and find her massacred corpse a later
autopsy revealing
she had been stabbed 17 times
it's all the more horrific is not just
the injury of the knife being plunged
through her back but also penetrating
the lungs
and she is essentially suffocating to
death on her own blood
initially gypsy is nowhere to be found
but then
a clue someone using dd's facebook
account
posts graphic and disturbing messages
investigators tracked the ip address to
nicholas godejon
once wisconsin authorities burst into
his home they find
gypsy alive and well in a shocking twist
nicholas decides to tell police what
happened
i did actually
[Music]
step forward do you know how many times
you stabbed her
you sat there four four times the fourth
one
i i felt they'd go into i think it would
have been her lungs
you had an individual that had total and
complete dominance
he essentially straddled her was on her
back
and began to plunge this knife into her
multiple times
but did nicholas act alone did he kill
dede and kidnap gypsy
the story takes a turn again did gypsy
know
her mother
honestly she
asked me to okay so so gypsy knew you
were going to do it because gypsy asked
you to
why did she ask you to do that because
she
[Music]
investigators pieced together a fuller
picture of the murder
gypsy wanted her mother dead
gypsy doesn't want to be controlled no
human
actually wants that she wants to break
free and understands that the only way
she that she can break free is by
her mother no longer being in the
picture so because
he sees this person that he loves being
abused and being hurt
he's willing to then engage in any kind
of behavior
that would succeed in that goal of the
two of them being together
nicholas explains that gypsy led him
into the house
gave him the knife and stood back as he
proceeded to stab dede to death
in the middle of the night
[Music]
okay and what did
[Music]
he just continued to kill her over and
over and over again he wanted to make
sure
that she was in fact dead this is what
we refer to as
overkilling nicholas however is not like
every other suspect
he was diagnosed with autism
autism spectrum disorder one of the
hallmarks is this
inability to have reciprocal social
interactions meaning everything seems to
be kind of just
one-sided for him frankly he seemed like
a very reasonable
a genuinely nice young man
during my interactions with him now his
interactions were a little bit
odd and stiff initially particularly
which is
very common with the autism spectrum and
nicholas was very mild in that spectrum
he also has an extremely low iq he
doesn't
understand complicated and complex
concepts
so just immediately being asked whether
or not he did it
yeah he would he would immediately
confess to the crime he has no reason
not to
i think nicholas's uh confession was
done
intelligently and voluntarily there's no
evidence of any coercion whatsoever
and he did so voluntarily so just
because he has a certain level of
diminished capacity
doesn't mean that he is not capable
of giving a provided confession that
will stand up in a court of law
this begs the question was he
manipulating gypsy
she thinking does she have the ability
to kind of conceptualize in that moment
what she has entered into it's almost
like she's entered into
a deal with another devil or was she
manipulating him so it's easy to see
how someone could influence him into
engaging in some
kind of problematic behavior i really
think she did
somewhat set him up in that regard and i
believe she convinced nicholas that if
they did run away together
her mother would always find them and it
would always end
[Music]
when we come back we don't just have
nicholas's side of the story
but gypsies as well had you discussed
alternative methods of
killing your mother yes what other
alternatives have you considered
poison arsons guns
[Music]
nicholas go to john confessed that he
murdered dede blanchard the mother of
his girlfriend gypsy blanchard
he claims gypsy urged him to do it so
that they could be together
and she could be free from the woman who
had been keeping her hostage for years
as we get further into the case the
details become more frightening
and the relationship between the two
more complex
ultimately nicholas and gypsy are both
arrested and charged for dede
blanchard's murder
at nicholas's trial gypsy would take the
stand
and testify for the defense she very
much still has feelings for him
and i certainly could understand why she
would want to testify on his behalf
just her telling her story on the stand
for that defendant garnet sympathy for
them both
and it also tended to show that the
defendant
also had emotional and mental issues
she explained that not only did she help
nicholas
she was the one who pushed him to do it
who talked too into killing your mother
i did i talked him into it
why not just tell somebody rather than
kill your mother why was that not
an option i truly didn't believe that
nobody
believed me if i told anyone my mother
had
legal documents in place saying that
i was incompetent for gypsy it was her
perceived key to the freedom
that she had so long to have she didn't
have the ability to
create what we view as kind of
normalized relationships with anybody
and what was your mom doing that caused
you to be more desperate
things were getting physically and more
physically abusive
the hitting was more the starving
was more and when it came to those
alarming
facebook posts from dede's account guess
who wrote them who made that post
i did did you make that post pretending
to be somebody else
yes and who were you pretending to be
nick
this is just her wanting to
make sure that all of the blame would
then be placed on
nicholas why would you make that post
claiming to be knit i wanted her to be
found
i wanted the cops to find her body i've
had this happen in a couple of cases
where
perpetrators have called in cases where
they
have left a body behind but yet they
don't want the body to essentially
decompose and be left all alone
yet it was nicholas who actually killed
dede
why didn't you kill your mother i didn't
believe i could do it
gypsy wasn't even in the room
[Music]
gypsy hiding in the bathroom is most
likely a protective
behavior it's probably the only
area in which she was able to be by
herself without her mother's influence
during cross-examination the state
chipped away at this idea that gypsy was
the mastermind
you mentioned that how the murder was to
take place
that was all up to the defendant correct
that is correct
and it was the defendant that told you
he wanted to stab your mom correct
and it was the defendant that told you
he wanted a knife
yes you never told him to
stab her 17 separate times right no
after the murder it only got worse he
wanted you to clean naked
yes sir because that
kind of turned him on yes sir
it's almost as if gypsy selected someone
maybe that parallels her mom someone
that
would be willing to control her to this
point that would
debase and humiliate her so he's pretty
much hyper-sexual
he's got this one person who
is engaging in sexual acts and sexual
behaviors and sexual conversations with
him
that he is interpreting as love and
again having autism spectrum disorder
means that he doesn't really
understand reciprocity nicholas gotta
john has quite the history
he was arrested in 2013 for allegedly
masturbating in a mcdonald's
and carrying a knife his apparent sexual
proclivities may have played a role here
as well
after the killing he and gypsy then have
sex
nicholas assures it was consensual
[Music]
okay and so what did you guys do when
you had sex
um he pretty much did all
gypsy however said she only agreed as a
way to keep nicholas
from doing something truly disturbing
when he asked you about raping
your mother you actually talked him out
right yes and you did so by offering
the alternative that he would be able to
rape you
after the murder correct that's correct
i wouldn't be surprised if the sexual
act was
actually consensual on both ends
again nicholas believing that he has
earned some kind of reward
and gypsy just giving in and
saying yes you have done what i needed
you to do
let me then give you this reward
they had sex in the context of the dead
being present
after they had done this it's almost
like some kind of twisted celebration
you're demonstrating ultimate control
over the dead those people that
you perceive to do great harm to you in
life
at one point during his interview
nicholas says that he
and gypsy have alter egos
originally refused to do it
okay and that's the reason why it was
instant
that it happened right away because my
needle size actually did it
okay the one thing he said was that
you're dead to me is one thing he said
who said that part of me said
he said okay that is more than one of
the sides
of each other there is a
[Music]
multiple personality disorders or
dissociative identity disorder
i don't believe either one of them have
that they needed to keep themselves safe
they needed to put on a mask
they needed to put on some kind of front
so gypsy needed to pretend herself to be
this invalid disabled individual in
front of dede
and she also needed to accommodate
nicholas's
more hyper-sexual kinds of urges for
nicholas
i believe that role-playing helped him
do things and think through things
differently but
it's not it wasn't not a psychotic type
thing it was more like
when we all to some degree say well i
need to
i need to channel the inner hulk into me
to get this difficult job done
in that same regard nicholas took on the
persona of an evil person in his own
mind
in order to get the task done despite
nicholas's low iq and autism
the jury didn't believe that he couldn't
appreciate what he did
and eventually convicted him of
first-degree murder
nicholas was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole
i think that he absolutely knew what he
was doing
there's a difference between not knowing
what you're doing and making a poor
decision
he is criminally liable but i really
feel that he doesn't deserve to spend
the rest of his life in jail
he has horrible uh emotional problems he
needs treatment
and he's not going to receive that
behind bars for the remainder of his
life
there was great planning that went into
this idea that he traveled
a great distance in order to pull this
thing off
i've seen those videotapes of him in
that interview room
he is fully aware of what is going on
and even
standing at the doorway before
the murder he was discussing in his own
mind
whether or not to go through with this
for gypsy she pleaded guilty to
second-degree murder
and was sentenced to 10 years in prison
so one would ask why would she plead
guilty so
a couple of reasons one the evidence was
very much
stacked against her not to mention to
kind of get this over
this trial was likely to be an intense
circus
and uh would have brought out a lot of
information
that probably a gypsy would not have
wanted to come out during the trial
even though she's locked away
surprisingly
gypsy appears to be in a much better
place than when her mother was alive
dede is no longer influential in
gypsy's life she's not creating medical
problems for gypsy
so despite being complicit in the death
of her mother
gypsy physically looks better
another reason for her to be happy she's
up for parole
in 2024 i think it's quite likely
that she would be paroled in 2024
because she is such a sympathetic figure
this woman suffered this abuse all the
medications
feeding tubes all these things went on a
wheelchair-bound when she didn't need to
be
for years you have to wonder how is she
going to support herself who is going to
take care of her
she very much will still need care from
another adult
based on everything that's occurred
nicholas killed dede blanchard
but what's not clear is who was
controlling who
in this murder you know who was in the
driver's seat
i think will be a question i don't know
that will ever
necessarily be answered however is it
possible
that he saw this as an opportunity yeah
i'll kill your mom
i'll do this for you but in the end i'll
control you
i'll debase you to the point where you
will strip down nude
you will clean up uh the blood from the
floor he's falling into a relationship
with her that he doesn't have the
capacity to understand
they're both influencing one another
but ultimately it is gypsy
who does the extreme behavior
of engaging in conversations that would
lead
nicholas to committing this murder
as a way of setting them both free
the gypsy indeedy blanchard story is
really something hard to believe
even spawning its own television show
yet the most tragic part of all
is people still wonder who exactly is
the victim in all this
dd gypsy nicholas
maybe all of them that's all we have for
you on prime crime tonight
leave us your comments on the blanchard
story on twitter and facebook with the
hashtag primecrimetonight
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
[Music]
you